[Musique]
et avec nous pour en parler sur ce
plateau thierry paul valette gilet jaune
vous est aussi le fondateur du comité
stopp zemmour 2022 bonsoir merci d'être
avec nous à vos côtés david xavier weiss
maire-adjoint et l'air de
levallois-perret soutien de valérie
pécresse bonsoir et merci également
d'être là pour nous accompagner en
liaison par skype cette fois-ci sergio
coronado conseiller en communication
politique ancien député europe ecologie
les verts
arthur parisse également porte parole du
parti la reconquête en le parti d'eric
zemmour merci à tous les deux aussi
d'être là on va s'intéresser fils ses
sketchs ou frère ce sondage est tombé ce
soir un sondage au donc ça gbagbo
consulting réalisée pour le figaro
et bien regardez ils sont seulement 9%
avoir suivi cette interview en anglais 9
% des interrogés 16% à l'avoir vu en
partie seuls 37% des français ont trouvé
le locataire de l'élysée convaincant
alors c'est il faut préciser le plus bas
niveau enregistré sur toutes les
interventions des manuels micron a
depuis le début de la crise sanitaire
enfin ça c'est un petit peu dur ski
français sur dix estiment que ce dernier
a tout simplement été mauvais sergio
coronado vos kg est aussi communicants
comment vous expliquer ces mauvais
résultats si j'ose dire parce que
forcément il avait l'oeil dessus
emmanuel macron sur ces sauvages de
postes une interview c'est l'exercice
c'est lui bref ça n'a pas plu
je pense que la politique c'est jamais
qu'un exercice de communication c'est
bien autre chose et de palme des
manettes d'un cros et son bilan son
passif en fait donc monde il se présente
devant les français en disant qu'il a
changé les français ont-ils tous
l'impression en fait de voir tout rejet
minerais non après vous papy fait de la
résistance mais ces deux fameux chanson
qui n'a pas pété non je n'ai pas changé
en fait les gens voyaient un résident
ont déconnecté de la réalité sociale du
pays
un président qui a beaucoup fait en
faveur des catégories les plus aisées
qui a malmené les catégories populaires
on se souvient la manière extrêmement
violente dans le monde et j'ai les gens
n'aient été traités on se souvient
également de sa politique à l'égard de
la jeunesse avec la réforme d abel et du
bourg l'écologiste que je suis c'est
quand même extrêmement chaud france et
c'est tout à fait même surprenant pour
quelqu'un de sa génération pas un mot
sur l'écologie pas un mot en fait sur
les crises que nous avons contre ont
aujourd'hui la fois la crise sanitaire
et la crise et la crise écologique avec
l'effondrement du vivant la crise
climatique est donc cet exercice cela ne
peut pas se résumer pour un candidat en
campagne
quand on est président de la république
en activité à un exercice de
communication d'inspiration très nord
américaine en fait on vient devant des
journalistes sans véritable
contradicteur en face de soi faire
amende honorable faire son mea culpa les
français ça si qu'ils ont vécu sous le
quinquennat d'emmanuel mâcon et 4 va
donner la parole pardonnez-moi sache
coronado en tout cas c'était pour la
première impression david xavier weiss
c'est quoi c'est un exercice qu'on a
peut-être trop vu où c'est vraiment lié
comme semble le penser sergio coronado à
la personnalité et au bilan emmanuel
macron ce que même giscard qui était à
l'époque un président en avance sur son
temps n'aurait pas fait aussi aussi
dépassé aussi suranné comme exercice on
est passé d'un mât cay et karito et de
youtube heures un mythe à l'elysée le 14
juillet à deux heures d'exercices est
pas la même cible non mais deux heures
d'exercices où il parle que de lui et on
peut s'il parle de lui en essayant de
dire j'ai changé mais en montrant que
c'est un président complètement
déconnecté il ne savait pas que des
français étaient à 10 euros la fin du
mois il ne savait pas qu'il y avait des
français des jeunes enfants qui ne
mangeaient pas forcément à leur fin en
france un français qui nous qu'un
président de la république ne connaît
pas les français il a fallu qu'il aille
sur le terrain rencontrer des maires ils
ont expliqué la réalité du terrain moi
j'ai enfin il avait dit soyez fiers
d'être des amateurs on est on a vu ce
que ça a donné à l'assemblée nationale
et on voit ce que ça donne et finalement
à l'elysée de l'amateurisme mais je ne
suis pas sûr que ce qu'on attend pour la
fonction suprême ce soit cet amateurisme
qui soit sacralisé on attend de
quelqu'un qui prenne de la hauteur il
n'a pas pris on attend quelqu'un qui
fasse un vrai mea culpa il n'a pas fait
bon c'est pas parce qu'il a dit hier je
me suis je m'excuse j'ai froissé des
gens ont dit en les traitant deux ans
les 30 ans nul quand effectivement
j'étais face à ceux qui sont riches à
ceux qui qui créent de la richesse je
vous ai traité de gens qui ne valait
rien oui ça c'était de toute façon
c'était une insulte mais elle reste on
sait très bien qu'il est c'est un fou
mais culpa lors des audiences assez
moyenne parce que c'est quand même une
première chaîne en france
nos confrères de tf1 emmanuel macron
donc le 15 sur tf 1 3 million 800 mille
téléspectateurs eric zemmour le
30/11 2021 sur tf1 plus de 6 millions
500 mille téléspectateurs une interview
avec gilles bouleau c'est donc deux fois
moins que votre poulain arthur paris ça
doit vous faire plaisir comment vous
vous l'expliquer c'est l'attrait de la
nouveauté contre quelque chose qu'on a
peut-être déjà vu et revu
écoutez je crois que les chiffres
parlent d'eux mêmes comme vous l'avez
dit on voit que les audiences suivent
eric zemmour quel que soit le média sur
lequel il s'exprime également lui n'est
pas neuf dans l'univers médiatique
puisque c'était un journaliste et
chroniqueur avant d'être candidat à la
présidentielle donc c'est pas
nécessairement
l'attrait de la nouveauté qui justifie
je pense là la réputation en tout cas le
leb le fait qu'eric zemmour aujourd'hui
il suffit de manière massive c'est
surtout parce qu'ils s'emparent des
thématiques qui concerne le lait
français emmanuel macron voit la fin de
son quinquennat a été le président du
grand déclassement
aujourd'hui d'un point de vue économique
sur l'explosion de la bête sur la
balance commerciale a extrêmement
déficitaire les gilet jaune qui ont
animé ce quinquennat et qui était un
révélateur du malaise qui né en france
lui aujourd'hui eric zemmour il a cette
capacité à parler aux français les
français n'écoutent les français le
suivent les français sont attentifs se
rappeler que le mouvement le parti
reconquête qui l'a lancé leur à
villepinte de 5 décembre il ya déjà plus
de 70 mille adhérents ce sont des
adhérents fiable puisque c'est à dire
débat sur eric zemmour à c'était sur
emmanuel macron pardonnez-moi temps mais
voilà je vous ai posé la question sur
cet ion part d'audience et pourquoi
emmanuel macron avait fait moins auront
sera en fera certainement ce débat une
autre fois mais pas monde et gilet jaune
parce que c'est vrai que
oui
pardonnez moi un petit mot
beaucoup plus d'audience et en effet la
nouveauté joue considéré pendant ce type
d'exercice mais rappelez-vous aussi les
commentaires après cette entrée en
campagne sur tf1 les
commentaires étaient plutôt négatif
contre à la perfection ce qui a valu
même
à débat sur eric zemmour on va parler
sans donner moi ça change rien on va
parler des gilet jaune parce qu emmanuel
macron et a été longuement interrogé
dessus ça a été évidemment une étape de
son quinquennat que retient-il de cet
épisode vous propose de l'écouter
la crise des gilet jaune juste pour
peut-être revenir d'un mot sur elle
elle dit quoi elle dit des peurs
profondes qu'il ya dans notre société et
au delà des violences dont on a parlé de
ce que j'évoquais elle
c'est à mes yeux le moment où les
françaises et les français
en particulier celles et ceux qui
travaillent parce que beaucoup des
filets jaunes ont un travail mais sont
mal payés c'est cette france qui se sont
invisibles et elle va sur les
ronds-points et le média gilet jaune 7
francs parce qu'elle dit vous ne vous
reconnaissez pas
et ça on peut pas le nier
valette il a compris les gilet jaune
emmanuel macron je suis complètement
abasourdi parce que il n'a pas quelques
mots à dire par rapport au gilet jaune
il a simplement un mot à dire gilet
jaune j'ai les jaunes ont peur seulement
il faut pas oublier qu'on a fait peur
aux idées jaune sur le terrain avec les
notamment violences policières ce qui
est terrible c'est que film d'ailleurs
pardonnez moi mais il dit la violence a
été légitime certains ont légitimé la
violence ont fait allusion à l'arc de
triomphe notamment puy-en-velay ont
parlé de cette violence ça vous a choqué
ou aussi
que ça et pas forcément les violences
sur le terrain oui bien sûr je suis un
petit peu un petit peu dommage mais
c'est un président qui stigmatisent ans
concernant l'épisode sur les champs
elysées à mon association d g des jo de
citoyens avaient averti monsieur
castaner qu'il y aurait à cette période
là des black blocs qui investirait des
champs elysées pour les saccages et
quelle réponse a été apportée 20 crs aux
alentours des de l'arc de triomphe donc
on a laissé faire on a encouragé cette
violence maintenant vous savez manuel da
cruz s'adresser aux français en disant
je commence à aimer les français louis
il ne les aime pas il commence à peine à
d aimer c'est ça qui est dramatique
maintenant vous savez quand on regarde
les chiffres mais a peut-être
éventuellement réputée présente les
aimer salut de prévente ul mans les
aimez mais vous savez un mois finalement
son intervention hier soir et les
chiffres sont là les français ne sont
pas dupes sa parole n'est plus entendue
et les désavouer il a mis à mal la
fonction présidentielle et puis c'était
quoi finalement c'était un mea culpa de
croque-mort qu'il a fait hier emmanuel
macron tourner autour de sa propre
personne non c'est non miscibles c'est
intolérable il faut pas s'étonner que
maintenant lié une part belle pour les
extrêmes dont la personne d'eric zemmour
mais ce qui est étonnant exercice c'est
qu'effectivement on a un président de la
république qui se comporte comme un
commentateur de la vie politique yari
commenté finalement l'activité des gilet
jaune et on a un commentateur de la vie
politique terry s'est moqué d'eux qui
veut devenir président de la république
on a quand même une inversion des
valeurs aujourd'hui une inversion des
valeurs ce chassé croisé qui est assez
étonnant et qui consterne finalement
beaucoup de téléspectateurs alors je ne
me suis pas eric zemmour mais reese et
moi a toujours été un commentateur de la
vie politique et là on al'impression de
l'art et de la république qui finalement
se rend compte de ce qu'est la france de
ce que sont les français de ce que
ressentent essentiel qui est dramatique
il ne se rend pas compte qu'il n'a pas
tiré les leçons et les conséquences de
ce qui s'est passé de la crise et j'ai
des choses acquises au gilet jaune force
est de constater qu'aucune réponse n'a
été réellement apporter voilà et dès
l'intervention du président emmanuel
macron finalement c'est une intervention
qui est centré sur lui même il est son
propre conseiller il se met en scène
lui-même il est narcissique lors d'une
soirée aux us qui dit quand il parle
toujours des db gilet jaune
cette petite phrase qu'on arrivait
quelque chose s'est passé un moment qui
fait que la foule laquelle parfois
c'était hugo trahi le peuple la foule
devient folle il ya eu de la violence
extrême dans nos rues dans la société
pendant beaucoup de samedi il y avait de
la violence qui a d'ailleurs touché
beaucoup de nos compatriotes des
commerçants il ya eu de la violence
aussi il ya des manifestants qui ont eu
je le sais à subir aussi beaucoup de
choses parce qu'ils se sont parfois
exposés certains ont été violents
eux-mêmes donc cette période a été une
période très dure la deuxième chose à la
crise je crois profondément c'est que
toutes les paroles ne se valent pas on
peut souffrir on peut avoir une parole
d'h on peut avoir un avis sur l'épidémie
mais de la crise des gilet jaune à
l'épidémie nous avons en quelque sorte
créé un système on pense que toutes les
paroles se valent c'est pas vrai il ya
des gens qui sont démocratiquement élu
par le peuple pour porter sa voix un
député de la république n'est pas
l'équivalent d'un manifestant quand il
s'agit de parler de la nation parce
qu'il a une légitimité démocratique
sergio coronado c'était cette deuxième
partie d'intervention qui m'intéressait
ça veut dire quoi c'est une façon de
remettre les manifestants à leur place
la mer
d'abord dormard d'abord il ya une
conception un peu surprenant de la
démocratie qui consisterait finalement a
confié les rênes du pays tous les
segments
un personnel politique
député président compris son qu'ils
aient jamais de comptes à rendre
rappelons-nous le mépris affiché par
emmanuel macron des corps intermédiaires
du parlement lui-même en fait de sa
majorité je crois que c'est une
conception surannée les gens ont envie
des citoyens anglais aujourd'hui de
participer à l'élaboration de la
décision politique de donner leur point
de vue d'exister comme citoyen sur la
scène publique et puisqu'il est assez
choquant également c'est cette façon
très psychologisante en fait de parler
des gilet jaune et gilet jaune ils ont
mis en lumière une réalité qui est celle
de notre pays d'inégalités profondes
inégalités territoriales
une partie de la population
effectivement qui travaillent et qui est
local du mois a très peu d'argent pour
finir ce mois là en fait des gens qui se
sont soulevés contre une politique qui
se voulait écologistes en fait avec
l'augmentation du prix des carburants
mais divisés à rêver à compenser les
cadeaux fiscaux qui avait été fait aux
plus riches au début du quinquennat donc
cette manière de parler de ce mouvement
social d'une ampleur sans précédent dans
l'histoire politique française n'avait
pas vu ça depuis presque un siècle en
fait entre en france comme d'une foule
compacte qui devient folle toujours ses
arguments et ses mots qui blessent
kystique l'a10 puis je note également
les l'absence d'empathie il ya eu des
violences il ya eu des personnes qui ont
perdu la vie il ya eu également des
personnes éborgné jamais emmanuel macron
nattier ce mea culpa avec l'utilisation
extrêmement brutal de la force des
pouvoirs de police qui me sont confiées
par le peuple français je trouve qu'on
est fait il confirme cette déconnexion
de la fonction payant ciel et la réalité
du pays qui est normalement appelées à
une vie d'arthur paris je vois que vous
inquiétez vous êtes d'accord avec sergio
coronado on vous attendait pas forcément
sur la même ligne mais soit
oui écouter
je suis d'accord il ya dix 10
précédemment moi ce qui m'a choqué hier
c'est cette phrase d'emmanuel macron jeu
les noter j'ai appris à mieux aimer les
français vous l'avez dit tout à l'heure
cette phrase est hallucinante il faut
que emmanuel macron au bout de cinq ans
finissent par commencé après
c'est un homme hors sol diplômé de l'ena
il a enchaîné brillamment une carrière
en tant qu'associé cherokee depuis le
secrétaire général ministre si oui c'est
un homme qui n'a jamais vécu comme comme
les français comme comme moi comme vous
il a jamais pris le bus le métro dont
qui sait pas ce que c'est d'avoir des
difficultés pour finir le mois il sait
pas ce que c'est te sentir agressés dans
les transports en commun donc moi ce qui
me ce qui me gêne profondément au dans
le bilan des manuels mccourt hier
c'était son autosatisfaction et sa sa
déconnexion totale et que le quotidien
des français effectivement quand il
parle du gilet jaune il ne parle que des
violences mais les gilet jaune ce
n'était pas juste des violences c'était
une crise profonde qui m'a étonné c'est
à dire je les ai compris jeunes se
sentent invincibles c'est un ballet on a
vu qu'ils avaient eux et cloud juste
après cette hausse de la taxe carbone
les 80 kilomètres heure donc c'est à
dire que vous avez le pouvoir dans au
parisien macro nhien déconnecté
déconnecté des réalités des français
c'est ça qui a produit les gilets jaunes
donc emmanuel macro n'a toujours pas
compris et l'impression que les jeunes
s'y est lui tombé dessus par hasard
parce que il a pas eu de chance non
c'était une réaction au mépris et la
condescendance qui sont vraiment des qui
sont inhérentes à sa personnalité
oui
une terrible erreur qui est fait et je
lui ai entendu encore dans la bouche de
monsieur c'est qu'on parle du gilet
jaune au passé selon léger légion nous
sont toujours présents sur le rond point
et notamment tous les samedis on ne les
voit pas on ne les entend pas ils n'ont
plus eu un écho médiatique tel qu il y a
deux ans il ya trois ans mais ils sont
toujours là et ce qui s'est passé il ya
deux ans peut revenir ça c'est la
première chose est la problématique
c'est que aujourd'hui les et il n'ya pas
que monsieur mâcon qui n'aiment pas les
français les politiques n'aiment plus
les français ils aiment leurs électeurs
et ça se limite à ça et quand on parle
de deux présidents qui est déconnecté
oui ils le sont tous monsieur zemmour
est déconnecté on l'a vu dans ces propos
notamment par rapport
à la réponse sur le logement des gens
entre autres c'est ça la réalité il faut
déconnecter aussi puisqu'on va lancer
son tiens ils font alors valérie
pécresse elle n'est pas déconnecté elle
est en train de se reconnecter
maintenant dans sa campagne et là ce
sera l'occasion aussi de devoirs et d'en
discuter comment va se situer par
rapport à l'amour même en avance et si
tu es aussi par après manuel macro et
quelles idées humanistes de gauche pour
est elle aussi s'approprier alors on met
trop salée droite essaie de la question
justement d'aller xavier weiss que
j'allais vous poser parce que quand on
entend et même un emmanuel macron comme
ça être un petit peu accusés finalement
d'être hors sol on se demande comment la
candidate de droite va se positionner
simplement tout simplement en étant en
prise avec les réalités du terrain et
valérie pécresse et président de la
région ile de france depuis plus de 5
ans 6 ans elle est en charge du
quotidien des franciliens quand tu la
crise sanitaire c'est valérie pécresse
la première des présidents de région à
avoir à porter des masques
là où il n'y en avait pas et là où
l'état ne me disait surtout ne mettez
pas il surtout il n'y en a pas valérie
pécresse est aussi celle qui au
quotidien gère tous les transports 50%
des réseaux ferrés sont en ile-de-france
métros trains rer et voies ferrées de la
chef 50% sont gérés par donc
sceptique
il se résume pas à l'île de france nous
avons fait aussi la la la france et
c'est l'agriculture ce sont les terres
et ils le font c'est
50 % de terres agricoles c'est aussi
parce qu'on oublie de france et où des
fraudes ou des barres hlm ou des
acheteurs qui veulent aimer parler lui
directement aparté parce que
tout simplement le représentant de l
électrique des graisses ne prenez pas
souvent les transports en ile-de-france
à l'état et aux herbes et le mrc est il
des dessertes notamment à intervalles
yeux je ne crois pas que le bilan
d'alerté qu'est-ce qui permettent
aujourd'hui d'avoir aussi fière allure
ce plateau messieurs j'ai moi j'ai mon
pass navigo sur moi il est resté en rade
est resté dans l'entré jeu jeu je peux
vous dire je prenais transport et
franchement il ya une amélioration après
on peut toujours avoir tout rediscuter
des ddv troc arrive en retard mais je
pense pas que ce soit le le le sujet une
élection aussi sérieuses que celles
quelle chance vous est présentée dans
quatre mois où on a en france
merci on a une on a une frange non non
on a un des sujets bien plus importants
que que les problèmes du rer b je pense
et qui concerne aussi et y compris la
province on a trois offres a mille
milliards d'euros de dettes que l'on
aime voient leur vie dans la ruelle
matheron 3000 milliards d'euros de
dettes et la dette d'aujourd'hui ce sens
large et demain
on va vous me donner la bonne transition
parce qu'on va terminer sur ce point
parce qu'il ya eu un petit pic décoché à
votre candidate je vous propose
d'écouter emmanuel macron qui a répondu
aux critiques à peine voilées de valérie
précresse qu'ils accusent de en gros de
cramer la caisse
la situation de la dette en france et
une situation qui impose de la vigilance
maintenant il ya deux faces et trois
façons de l'aborder une façon qui
consiste à dire après moi le déluge
génération égoïste laissons la dette à
nos enfants ils se débrouilleront où
nous allons répudié cette dette les gens
qui nous ont donné l'argent ne le
reverront jamais je ne crois pas à cette
formule parce que je pense que si c'est
le message qu'on envoie il est
irresponsable c'est à dire que nos
enfants auront à la payer mais surtout
les gens ne vous font plus confiance et
au fait ça parce qu'il vous prêteront
plus d'argent donc je doute je ne
recommande pas cette option il ya une
deuxième option qui est l'option que
j'appellerai père fouettard faut couper
tout de suite c'est ce qu'on a fait
depuis un temps sa maladroite en fait
son thème maintenant la droite arrive en
disant les pas de paul était en disant
cramer la caisse en dix ans elle revient
avec le rigorisme budgétaire en disant à
lyon le prix n'a jamais marché c'est à
dire ceux qui ont fait ça ont ensuite
augmenté les impôts comme jamais bon il
n'a pas admis qu'ils s'adressent à
valérie pécresse mais quand même un
journaliste voilà notre confère la la
soulever votre réponse ce monsieur
maintenant qu'ils étaient le le ministre
de l'économie de françois hollande ne
peut pas donner des leçons il a quand
même créer 3000 milliards d'euros de
dettes et je ne sais pas et d'ailleurs
il ya il n'ya pas donner de leçon ou en
tout cas de deux pistes de solution
trois mille milliards d'euros de dettes
d'aujourd'hui c'est les impôts de demain
fatalement soit céder un pouce cassé des
services publics en moins et on a vu ce
que c'était les services publics en
moins c'est justement des territoires
ruraux qui seront abandonnés et
aujourd'hui on en paie le prix on en a
payé le prix avec la crise et gilet
jaune la crise et les jaunes c'est quoi
ces trente ans d'abandon des territoires
ruraux idée des zones périurbaines c'est
important de le dire mais non mais c'est
encore el en outre deere et sa une la
même taille leleu l'audace ou en tout
cas le courage de le reconnaître hier ça
prouve encore une fois qu'il n'est pas
il ne connais pas ni les français ni la
france est l'âme ni les français ni la
france et c'est bien dommage pour entrer
dans la rue baby clermont 4 ans presque
50 ans apprendre à connaître et aimer
les français et aujourd'hui on se rend
compte de quoi que cette année en
formule tout ça n'a servi à rien ça a
servi à rien c'est le dernier tour de
table sergio coronado oui dans un débat
politique faut parler des déclarations
et des engagements concrets ce serait
sympa que
vous dites ou boyer supprimer les 150000
aux fonctionnaires que valérie pécresse
annonce il était élu président de la
république est-ce que c'est dans les
hôpitaux dans les écoles est-ce que
c'est dans d'autres services publics ce
serait un élément en tout cas ce sera
l'objet le croyez moi
et je vous inviterai volontiers fait
beaucoup moins peur qu eric zemmour bon
et est bon alors voilà le mot de la fin
pour vous arthur paris elle fait moins
peur que enfin tout le monde fait moins
peur manifestement qu'eric zemmour c'est
ce qui semble être partagée sur sur ce
plateau et vous avez le mot de la fin
profitez-en je vous remercie écoutez moi
j'écoute le porte parole de valérie
pécresse c'est bien j'entends que c'est
une bonne gestionnaire c'est une
gestionnaire donc moi je pense ça le
fera une excellente ministre d'emmanuel
macron pourquoi pas sa première ministre
ce sera une femme en plus donc ça
pourrait être un clin d'oeil important
pour mac ont maintenant eux hier il faut
souligner qu emmanuel macron a beaucoup
visé eric zemmour dans ses phrases dans
des sous-entendus et à juste titre
pourquoi parce que aujourd'hui règlement
il porte un projet de civilisation il
porte un projet pour la france et donc
emmanuel macron a bien compris que
l'adversaire de son camp puisque elle
m'a coincé le grand libéral legrand un
mondialiste legrand individus hors sol
et que voilà le représentant aujourd'hui
de la souveraineté de la souveraineté
populaire cette france patriotes et de
cette france enraciné si eric zemmour
est donc valérie pécresse encore une
fois je pense qu'elle ferait une
excellente ministre du budget des
manuels macro mais je pense qu'elle
devrait candidater pour 2022 visiblement
tout le monde est d'accord sur le
plateau pour dire qu' il n'y a pas
beaucoup de différence entre maintenant
et de grèce le mot de la fin pour la
danse après page et oui vous savez
monsieur zemmour monsieur zemmour lui
veut casser une civilisation et prend en
otage l'élection présidentielle pour ce
faire et ça c'est dramatique et ça c'est
terrible là est la vraie différence
sincèrement qu'on soit de droite
construit de gauche contre des extrêmes
la seule candidate à pouvoir battre
emmanuel macron et si on veut une vraie
alternance à les prochaines c'est
valérie pécresse donc moi je vous invite
tous si vous une vraie alternance art
journalières qui reste que vous que ce
soit ou non qu'on est tous quatre
semble-t-il emmanuel mcs rouabah bel et
bien lancé la campagne 1 depuis hier
soir merci à tous les quatre en tout cas
d'avoir été avec nous et c'est la fin